well we were thinking of getting one of
our films on hulu how would you go about
doing that
yeah we we worked with roger over at
keno nation um and through his help we
got the film up on amazon
amazon instant as well as hulu and
it's fascinating because um the key
donation system basically allows you to
upload your
film uh either at a
pro res or avid dnx file and then
basically like that upload basically
then gets converted to the various
um you know codecs and the various ways
that you know i think amazon has
all these different streaming you know
if you're on a slow brow
you know you can watch in full hd so
there's like a full range of
the ways that your film has to go out to
these different platforms
and yeah it's been great you basically
set your
your chapter markers where your ad
points are going to come in
and you upload your you know your poster
file and your artwork file and your
synopsis
and you got to have your closed captions
um you know part of your upload
yeah so to all of these digital
platforms were you able to just
give them one type of digital file or
did it vary because of you're saying
these different codexes
well yeah i mean key donation takes your
one dnx file or pro as file
and then you know for us i think it was
like a 125 gigabyte
um file of the full film in
avid dnx format and then basically from
there it's processed through the key
donation system and put out to the
different places they work with
you know snag films and hulu and amazon
hopefully you know eventually we'll get
on itunes but um
but then we also put the film up
ourselves to sites like vimeo
vhx indie reign we also have the film on
indieflix
which is just a fascinating you know
membership where you're part of the
indieflix membership and then you get to
have access to all the films there
have you ever heard about making your
film into an app and then putting it on
itunes that way or
i haven't heard that okay yeah take that
out
could be it could be an app and you
could just watch the whole film inside
the app
yeah i thought there was some because it
is so hard to get on itunes that
somebody was saying well there's a way
around it if you make it into an app and
then
but then you have to get an app
developer so it just costs all this
money but
i don't know it's tough because you know
it's the difference between do it all
yourself and learn how to frickin do it
first
which is always frustrating when you're
like okay how do i do this thing i don't
know
well find out and you're like okay this
is how you do it
or you know hire someone out that knows
how to do it already and that's the
difference between you know
paying someone else to do it or doing it
yourself right